april 10th 1912
the titanic a british passenger liner
carrying 2435 passengers departs from
southampton england and begins its
journey across the atlantic
its final destination is new york city
the ship of course would never reach the
big apple because on april 14th
at 11 40 p.m it hit an iceberg about 400
miles off the coast of newfoundland
and sank on april 15th at 2 20 am but
everyone knows this what most people
don't know
is what happened to the passengers on
the ship when it sank
what happened to the passengers as the
ship traveled from the surface of the
ocean
down 2.4 miles to its watery grave
was it possible for passengers to stay
alive while the ship sank to the ocean
floor
or would most have expired within the
first few seconds
well luckily physics and physiology can
help unravel what happened during that
10 minute descent
and oh my it's not pretty
ok let's start at the service level just
before the ship is fully submerged
there's 20 lifeboats in the water
holding 708 passengers
and on the ship there's about 1500 still
alive most people are distributed at the
stern and some are alive and trapped in
the middle part of the ship
in the dining halls in the many long
hallways or in their own cabins
they can't reach the stern due to the
ship's steep 30 degree angle
suddenly the 16 000 ton stern tears from
the bow and the ship sinks into the
ocean within 15 seconds
let's first start at 100 feet under
water here the water pressure is 45
pounds per square inch or
three atmospheres on dry land the
atmospheric pressure is 14.7 pounds per
square inch
or one atmosphere which is about
equivalent of a bowling ball being
exerted on every square inch of your
body
fun fact the more you decrease in
altitude that is go below sea level on
dry land
the atmospheric pressure increases every
33 feet you descend the atmosphere
increases by 22.6 grams or
0.05 pounds per square inch so you can
go pretty deep below sea level
underwater though it's much different
because water is 800 times heavier than
air
every 33 feet you descend the
atmospheric pressure increases by 14.7
pounds per square inch
this explains why the pressure at 100
feet is already 3 atmospheres heavy
and boy do we have a long way to go the
ship is at 100 feet
underwater with a pressure of 3
atmospheres which sounds like a lot but
it's really not 100 feet is pretty
normal for most professional free divers
and some even go beyond 300 feet however
this depth is still notable as it's
where physiological effects become
really apparent
the pressure begins to compress gases in
your body one significant place where
this happens is your lungs
which begin to shrink for visualization
this empty soda bottle full of air is
submerged 75 feet under water
the bottle is shrinking because the
gases in it are being compressed
at 75 feet the atmospheric pressure is
about 33.4 pounds per square inch
or 2.2 atmospheres upon resurfacing the
gases re-expand
now the ship is at 300 feet at this
depth there is nine atmospheres of
pressure or 133 pounds per square inch
surprisingly at this depth and pressure
the human physiology can still function
but barely professional free diver and
williams give a detailed description to
the new york post
of what it was like to dive down to 330
feet without
any scuba gear i was surrounded by pitch
black darkness
and my throat felt like it was being
choked
you're crushed by the water pressure
your chest shrinks to half its size
and your trachea begins to collapse so
at 300 feet passengers could have still
been alive and possibly conscious
however they would have been in extreme
discomfort and near to blacking out
by 500 feet fatal effects begin
happening to the body
at this step the average person cannot
free dive and would need scuba gear to
stay alive
pressure is at 15 atmospheres or 222
pounds per square inch
without the use of scuba gear breathing
would not be possible
as the lungs are too compressed normally
alveoli exchange oxygen into the blood
but because the lungs are compressed
soar the alveoli thereby reducing
surface area and making gas exchange
impossible
in fact the pressure is so high that
nitrogen gas in your blood dissolves
into nerve cell membranes
obviously this isn't supposed to happen
in human physiology
and as a result nerve signaling becomes
disrupted causing tremors dizziness
hallucinations and high probability of
blacking out
this is what any living passengers would
have felt in addition to a compressed
chest and throat the titanic sank a
distance of 2.4 miles
so why are we focusing on the first 100
300
and 500 feet of the descent well because
the first 500 feet is the zone where
passengers could have theoretically
still been alive
given how fast the ship descended
however after 500 feet passengers would
not be alive
no matter where they were in the ship if
there were any air pockets in the ship
they would have been imploded by now
and holding your breath at 500 feet is
physiologically impossible for the
average person
as the ship passed 500 feet passengers
would have blacked out and then
succumbed to the increasing pressure on
the lungs and throat
not to mention the physiological effects
of gases dissolving into the nervous
system
since the titanic took about 10 minutes
to hit the ocean floor
the first 500 feet would have taken
about 15 to 20 seconds to reach so any
passengers still alive when it sank
would have lasted about
20 seconds and 30 seconds at absolute
best
yet we still have 12 028 feet left to go
so do you want to know what happened to
the passengers when they reached the
bottom of 6 000 pounds of pressure
let's find out there are records of
people free diving down to 500 feet and
deeper
austrian freediver herbert nitch holds
the world record for the deepest free
dive of 702 feet
the only other record of someone going
deeper is egyptian diver ahmed gabir who
dived down to 1089 feet
or one-fifth of a mile with scuba gear
at this depth the pressure is 33
atmospheres or 485 pounds per square
inch
beyond this depth even with scuba gear
we don't have any records of what
happens to a human body
especially at 2.4 miles deep yet by
applying the effects of physics to human
physiology we can get a fairly good
understanding of what happens
somewhere between 1089 feet and 12
528 the bodies would have succumbed to
the extreme pressures of the ocean
we can't say for sure at which depth
these effects would have happened
one mile 1.5 miles 2 miles we're just
not sure
however we can say what would have
happened at the end of the 2.4 mile
descent
passengers trapped in the many
compartments of the ship which by now
would be full of water
would have been exposed to the complete
effects of pressure at 2.4 miles
or 380 atmospheres or 5584 pounds per
square
inch more simply as ralph white put it
who was one of the members who helped
discover titanic in 1985
said the pressure is like placing a
human between two steel plates
and driving a train over them at that
pressure
all gaseous volumes would have been
imploded and crushed to pieces
this is what happened to the stern when
it sank when the titanic broke in too
the open end of the stern sunk downward
causing air to get trapped inside
as the stern descended gases were
increasingly compressed until the stern
imploded from the pressure
this explains why it's so badly damaged
compared to the bow
this same scenario happened to the
passengers the body has multiple gaseous
cavities in it such gaseous locations
include the lungs
gi tract and sinus cavities in the head
when the passengers would have gotten to
this depth
all the gaseous volumes would have been
crushed flat and into pieces
that means a crushed abdominal cavity
chest cavity and sinus cavities in the
face
at this point you may be asking why the
near six thousand pounds per square inch
of pressure wouldn't crush the bodies
into a fine paste
well unlike gases solids and liquids
can't be compressed
the human body is mostly water and bones
are solid so neither can be crushed
because water applies pressure equally
over a surface
this is why artifacts have been taken
from the site untouched
ceramic plates remain unbroken because
they're solid and can't be compressed
this is why only the gaseous volumes in
the body were crushed because again
gases can be compressed as for the
passengers remains
nature takes its course and we can say
with very high accuracy as to what would
have happened
two canadian criminologists from simon
fraser university
wanted to see what exactly happened when
the land animal decayed at the bottom of
the ocean
two pig carcasses were placed one
thousand feet at the bottom of the sales
sea
it was discovered that after three days
both pig carcasses were devoured
down to the bone the creature that was
able to pull this off was an amphipod
and it wasn't just one but hundreds of
thousands of them
from here immense pressure and water
dissolving the remains would have made
the bones disappear within about five
years
so there you have it any burning
questions and what happened to the
passengers of the titanic
made clear when the ship began its
descent underwater
any living passengers would have lasted
only 20-30 seconds at best due to the
increasing
pressure at the bottom of the ocean
passengers gaseous cavities in the face
chest and abdomen would have been
crushed finally amphipods would have
consumed the passengers down to the bone
within three to four days
and bone would have fully dissolved in
the water after about five years
all right so for the update um now i've
had questions for science as a full-time
channel now for about three or four
years
um and i enjoy science very much but
before i
was actually a scientist before i
majored in science i actually majored in
history and then i
changed majors back in college but i
wanted to be a history teacher but
life happens so i decided to make a new
channel
which is now called questions for
history
so i can kind of be a history teacher on
youtube as well as a science teacher
um so right now there's no content
but by the time this video is uploaded i
will have content on this channel
in fact the first video is going to be
on why we don't build castles anymore
both for the civilian and military
reasons it should be very interesting i
think you'll like it
but yeah so new channel questions for
history
if you like history check it out if you
like science check it out they're both
here
but that's that's the update thanks for
watching and stay tuned
you